I think I wanted to live in Berlin
almost as soon as I discovered it what
was below the surface as soon as I
started to to meet the people here who
were engaging in their own projects and
that's kind of the thing that I wanted
to do too and it seemed like a great
place to do it
Oliver Miller was born in 1972 in San
Francisco the youngest of two brothers
seven years later the family moved to
New Mexico
Oliver studied architecture and was
active in the arts eventually he and
other American artists were invited to
participate in an exhibition in Potsdam
just outside Berlin
after finishing his studies in 2000 he
moved to Berlin at first on a temporary
visa and with no real plans then he got
the idea to open a bar it was such a
success that he branched out a few years
later and opened a restaurant
the Nalu diner it's modeled on the
classic diner where breakfast is served
at any time of the day the inspiration
for the restaurant actually came from
going out to clubs and the desire to
have this kind of food late at night
it's a very common thing in America to
have a diner breakfast
in the 24-hour diner at 4:00 or 5:00 in
the morning with bottomless cups of
coffee an American breakfast means first
and foremost lots of combinations
patrons that the Nalu diner can pick can
choose from a variety of options the
menu is centered around eggs for
instance on toast or with hash browns
around 50 combinations are possible
aside from breakfast the diner fries up
classic hamburgers
I loved especially the idea of having
unlimited amount of coffee that you can
get all the time that's that's great and
and plus the hospitality that they the
place the waiters are showing to you and
and the friendliness is really really
great I lived in the USA for a year this
is really quite authentic it's very
close to an American diner food is
fantastic very American two fillings you
get hooked on it and you keep coming
back this markup gun of you know what
mainly sets the American breakfast apart
from the European continental breakfast
are the many cooked components but most
of them can be fixed relatively quickly
and easily Americans call it short-order
cooking pancakes are a breakfast
standard to make them nice and thick the
American Way
the batter has to be right when the
pancakes start getting little bubbles in
the pan they're ready to be flipped
the Naaru diner also serves their own
spiced breakfast sausage patties
a Denver omelet is fried with bell
pepper and chunks of ham and of course
eggs are an essential part of any
American breakfast
all the entrees have served on one
single plate the sweet and the savory
together when one orders breakfast in
American diner the question of how you
want your eggs is is an open one there
is no standard in America you have
scrambled eggs or fried eggs or poached
eggs it's really your choice
the server will always ask how do you
want your eggs and I love hearing this
question because it really means it's
going to be an American breakfast when
you can decide how it is you exactly
want your excellent Oliver Mellor sees
his restaurant as a project that keeps
evolving
the pictures on the walls were made by
himself for artists friends and he keeps
changing them for new ones the
decorations are a hodgepodge of personal
objects and mementos Miller opened his
restaurant in 2012 in Berlin's Eastern
District of prints lat
he lives close by and enjoys the
neighborhoods diversity classes guests
come from all over the world and suits
the Naaru diner the name Nalu diner came
from a conversation with my one of my
old partners who grew up in Hawaii and
actually I've never been know why but
the name is Hawaiian it actually means
surf but not surf in terms of surfing
but surface like a noun it's the top of
the wave as it's breaking and yeah we
just thought okay that's a good name for
for the place at least twice a year
Oliver Miller gets homesick and flies
back to the United States sometimes even
considers moving back entirely someday
maybe
hi we've made a Denver omelet and
buttermilk pancakes and homemade sausage
patty enjoy